back in april 2019 the greatest stock
trade in the history of the world was
completed
mackenzie scott bought amazon stock here
in 1993 an entire year before the
company was founded
and sold here in 2019 26 years later for
a staggering 35 billion dollars in
profit
but instead of buying and selling amazon
stock it was through marrying jeff bezos
without a prenup
and divorcing jeff bezos and after just
four months of finalizing the divorce
she came out as the third richest woman
in the world a position she still holds
then there's poor old elon who didn't
just go through one pricey divorce
not two pricey divorces but three the
first was with justine
the first love of his life they married
for eight years after their relationship
began in college
it's definitely very cool i like it a
lot congratulations
they had six sons together and the
divorce took two years
and in california the wealthier spouse
in the divorce has to pay for both sides
of the legal battle even if they weren't
the aggressor so elon had to pay at
least four million dollars in legal and
accounting fees
which comes out to a hundred seventy
thousand dollars per month
in the end justine received 20 million
dollars after tax in the form of a house
and support payments which comes out to
a nice 20 000
per month dividend then came elon's
second marriage with actress tallulah
riley they divorced in 2012 leaving
riley with 4.2 million dollars
then they made up got married again and
then divorced again a year later
leaving riley with a much more
respectable 16 million dollars
so in the end riley also got a total of
20 million dollars just like his first
wife justine
which brings us to bill and melinda
gates bill married molina on a hawaiian
island around the same time as basil's
in 1994.
27 years later in 2021 they filed for
divorce and are still working out how
much of that 130 billion
empire melinda is going to get both
sides have an impressive inexpensive
legal team too
with mrs gates having the same lawyer
that represented michael bloomberg and
ivana trump
and bill having the same lore that
represented mark zuckerberg and his
friends with warren buffett
bill has already given her 2.4 billion
dollars worth of shares
if melinda gets just 25 of the 130
billion dollars
that will make her the sixth richest
woman in the world just like that now
gentlemen before you go
calling all women gold diggers unless
you're divorcing the ultra wealthy
usually in america the real gold diggers
that profit off of a divorce
are the divorce lawyers the judges the
family courts what we'll call the
divorce industrial complex
see divorce is a business just like
anything else a 50 billion dollar
business according to a documentary
called divorce corp
when you walk past a wedding the first
thought in your mind should not be oh
how sweet
it should be great we have more
inventory when i passed a wedding
i'd think to myself that's inventory and
here is how this industry works
[Music]
i've had cases where they've spent 20
million dollars in fees the real
standard is
how much money can we make off these
people that's the standard
people can get as much justice as they
can afford
and that most people cannot afford any
justice
at all the biggest single reason for
divorce in this country
is marriage think this text animation
looks cool how about this one
or maybe this one these animations and
some of these stock footage you see in
this video is from storyblocks today's
sponsor
storyblocks is the all-in-one platform
that lets you download unlimited stock
footage
audio music images animations basically
all the assets you need to make a video
storyblocks has them all in one place
with a single affordable subscription
and that's what separates storyblocks
from the rest most sites make you pay
for just music or just video or worse
yet they make you pay per download but
with storyblocks you get
everything with unlimited downloads all
in one very reasonable subscription
so making pro level edits like this
[Music]
it's as easy as clicking download so if
you're an aspiring creator marketer or
video editor that wants to make videos
faster than ever before
pause the video and go to
storyblocks.comtrend right now with the
link below to sign up for their
unlimited all access plan there's no
commitment and you can cancel at any
time that's storyblocks.comtrain with
the link below
when we're drunk on love and we get
married we have this ideal fantasy
that's going to be perfect that we're
going to live happily ever after
charlie what are you doing dude but the
numbers show otherwise
with nearly 40 of all marriages ending
in divorce
meaning that divorce is almost half as
common as marriage itself
so we have the supply there are plenty
of divorces out there and plenty more to
come but how do we profit off of it
well what most people don't realize is
that in america marriage is not just a
vow of love
but a financial contract the most
important and easiest financial contract
you'll ever enter into
some people plan for months a basic
marriage ceremony can be completed in 10
minutes
all that's really required is proof of
age and a 50
fee for a marriage license but getting
divorced is far from easy
when you get married all your cash your
car your house your assets are all
pulled together under you and your
spouses
we'll call it a joint partnership
neither one of you really owns any of
your wealth
the marriage owns all of it so when you
divorce both of you have to determine
who gets what
since during a divorce things get pretty
heated between the two of you your
spouse might claim that you cheated were
abusive whether that's true or not
and your spouse would demand that they
get the house that you paid for all your
money the kids etc
you can't have that so you fight back
and this fight the fight over your
wealth is where all the money is made
and how do you fight this fight as a
spouse well that's where the lords come
in
[Music]
so you hire a divorce lawyer to protect
yourself against your spouse taking your
stuff
you pay them maybe six hundred dollars
an hour seven hundred dollars an hour
and maybe even more insane numbers
the rate was 600 an hour in the gold
coast of fairfield county it's 6.50 an
hour i'm not saying i'm worth 700 an
hour
but that's what i charge i said to the
litigants i want you to know cost us 27
000 an hour i said after two hours
we will have spent more than most people
in this courthouse making a year
the more you charge the more people are
willing to pay because they feel that
money equals skill why do people pay
such high rates because they're
desperate they have a lot to lose and
they don't imagine this divorce taking
that long right
i mean it's just a divorce litigation
lasted for over a year
and my divorce has lasted now over six
and a half years i'll be close to eight
years
eight years so you two file for a
divorce which is easy but actually
completing that divorce is much harder
even if both parties agree to divorce it
needs to be approved by a family court
judge
and inside the family courtroom is where
the real fun begins
[Music]
family courts are like the wild west
because parts of the u.s constitution
don't apply there
you have no right to an attorney if you
can't afford one and you don't get a
jury
only the judges have the final say since
you don't have a right to an attorney
one might think that these courts would
simplify the divorce law so you can
represent yourself
easily but they don't the rules for
family courts differ from state to state
and are usually very complicated
because why not the more complex the law
the more reliant you are on lawyers the
more they can charge
the lawyers are the legislatures they
make the laws the more laws and the more
complex they are
the more we have to pay them so the
first order of business is finding out
how much money the two of you have
between you to fight over
you guys fill out an income and expense
statement list out your net worth
everything you own
and the first thing that lawyers do is
find out exactly how much money you and
your spouse have
you fill out an income and expense
declaration basically
just to find out how much you're worth
and once the lawyers and judge have a
clear picture of what you have
then the fight begins
as a lawyer you're paid hourly therefore
it's in your best interest to keep the
fight going
to pour more and more gasoline onto the
fire because if your client's divorce is
settled you lose your income stream
the attorneys definitely don't want to
settle the cases because once they do
their income stream has been cut off so
you wouldn't attempt you want to push
your client to fight to get more money
from their spouse
she's a scumbag in my professional
experience she's asking for too much you
need to fight back
you deserve better than this don't let
him have the last word
once the lawyers find out how much each
side is worth they tempt their clients
with the prospect of getting more money
through fighting it has become about
winning and that's both from the
economic perspective and from the sort
of emotional perspective
what you have is a tinderbox and
virtually anything can ignite that
tinderbox and the lawyers frankly
often are throwing gasoline on that fire
so your spouse starts making wild
accusations about you to get your stuff
even if they're not true you have to
fight back or else you lose everything
which means more billable hours for the
lawyers it turns out the court system is
designed to create conflict
many lawyers encourage their clients to
be as aggressive as possible
tempting them with winning more money
and once someone starts making
accusations towards you in court
you have no choice but to fight back
because if you don't
you could lose it all when one party
files in paperwork the other party has
to respond or else they lose by default
one party files something you have to
respond
if you don't respond you either lose by
default
or if it's a content petition you land
yourself in jail
so one of your goals should be to paper
the other side until they run out of
money to keep fighting
you're a lawyer you write a nasty letter
her lawyer has to write a nasty letter
it's just a great system
essentially paper the other side until
they can't take it anymore
and the lawyers have been granted
complete immunity in family court
a lawyer can say or do anything no
matter how false or cruel
and waste tens of thousands of dollars
intentionally and maliciously
and they cannot be sued for malicious
prosecution or excessive litigation
if there are kids to fight over even
better because we all know most parents
will do almost anything for their kids
the kids are the pawns i use the term
little bags of money
when there is a contested case over
physical
custody of the children and this will
drag on for six months
a year six years maybe even eight years
maybe even longer than the time you
spent married together
litigation lasted for over a year and my
divorce has lasted now over six and a
half years
i'll be close to eight years eight years
until eventually one side or both sides
run out of money to pay the legal fees
but it doesn't have to end there if your
client is still really heated their egos
on the line they can't lose
you might be able to convince them to go
into debt to keep fighting and therefore
keep paying you
so how do people pay for all this when
the liquid cash went
out at that point there he says well i
understand you have a hundred thousand
dollar
line of credit which i had to go ahead
and use that
in order to pay uh for my legal defense
a lot of people go into debt
as a result of their divorces some
attorneys automatically
put a lien on your house just to make
sure that eventually they get paid
and if that isn't enough the court can
even order you to sell everything you
own
but eventually everyone runs out of
money everyone runs out of credit and
when you finally
milked all you can for your client it's
time to pack up your books close the
case and chase the next divorce
[Music]
the attorneys aren't alone in this
industry though the other major players
are the judges
like we mentioned family courts are
special in that people don't have the
right to an attorney or jury
all that power the power to determine
the financial future of these couples
rests in your more nobler hands
how much money they owe collecting the
money that they owe who gets the house
who gets the kids how much child support
does one side have to pay the other for
the rest of their lives
so much power and with great power comes
great opportunities to be bribed
there's very few businesses in america
where
you can sit back and a judge sends you
the business
and a judge collects your money for you
and that money
gets to you for sure and the beauty of
this is
all they got to do is get in good with
the judges
but the real money for being a family
court judge is when you retire from
public service
and walk straight into a private law
firm for a giant private salary
all within one day no waiting period and
unlike other public officials
judges do not have a waiting period
between public and private practice
and it's all these factors and
incentives that come together to make
for one hell of a racket
from the fact that it's so easy to be
blinded by love to the legal and
financial contract of marriage in the us
that almost no one knows about when they
get married
to the wild west family course and the
incentives lawyers and judges have
within it
the lawyers and judges rake in the cash
and the average person that gets
divorced experiences a 77
drop in wealth one interesting note is
that divorce rates have been on the
decline for a while now
since more and more people are getting
married at an older age
and there's still a good argument for
getting married marriage is like the
lottery
you're probably not gonna win but if you
win what you win
is so great that it's worth trying it's
worth buying the ticket and taking the
ride
so if you do get married maybe don't
follow in the steps of jeff bezos and
elon musk
and just get a prenup
[Music]
as usual when we go over topics like
these are all divorce lawyers and judges
bad
probably not but you get the point if
you want to support the channel
financially check out today's sponsor
storyblocks with the link below
storyblocks.com
jtran for unlimited video audio
animations
every all the assets you need to make a
video storyblocks has them with one
simple monthly subscription
if you want to win a thousand dollars
all you have to do is submit a video
idea for the channel that you think will
get at least a million views
you have to submit the exact title and
thumbnail that the video would use and
if i use your exact thumbnail and title
word for word
i will send you a thousand bucks no one
wanted for this video because
i was gonna make this video anyways and
all the thumbnails and titles that were
submitted for this video topic
just weren't all the way there if you
want more video essays just like this
one on the most provocative stuff
in the world of business subscribe so
you don't miss out and we're also on
tick tock now the first video got like
700k views
which is really cool so that will be
linked down below as well for tick tock
that is going to wrap it up for this
video thank you so much for watching
you've been awesome i've been jake stay
dangerous out there and i will see you
guys
in the next one
you